oh there it is that's why
oh I didn't put it live yet that's why
it's not working there it is
also what I have to do is I have to take
this and copy it over to this thing
that's what it was I see this [ __ ] is
complicated y'all oh I can hear myself
wait turn this [ __ ] down okay that's
really loud turn that [ __ ] down son
alright so anyway I got this game anthem
and I'm gonna play it it's pretty good
so that's why I was playing apex with
the with the worst fireteam voice but
apex legend is like apex legend is a
suit it's a good game you know it's a
really good game but I just suck at
those type of games we have to shoot
other people it's like my guns never
work you know I mean so now I'm gonna
play a little anthem to let y'all you're
part of there we go little anthem with
Griffin Durr burn hope you guys like the
Dayne episode if you if you're watching
it it was a masterpiece somebody said
well sup y'all alright can you hear me
now chat I hope to check you hear me now
I think you can from the looks of my
thing you can hear me I hope it's not
too loud so I'm gonna play this game
anthem let y'all know what I think about
it Gruffudd gaming episode 6
Cooper gaming wait there it is goof it
coming up top six it's all about it um
I know I should have like a I should
have a theme song for anthem Griffin
Jamie I don't think that's good I don't
think that's good y'all I don't think
that's good but this game is like I'm
not sure if I like this game people did
like I don't know if people play destiny
do y'all play destiny
cuz this is like a little bit like
destiny but like a little bit more like
you could fly I kind of like the flying
aspect of the game so that's pretty good
but I don't know if I I don't know if
the game's fun I don't know if it's like
is sustainable to keep you know I mean
but we'll see you know what I mean
for like I just god I guess so board
somebody's getting this okay first of
all the game looks beautiful okay and
then once again you know they trying to
be all ethnic I don't know if this dues
white I don't know what he is you know I
mean he looks like he could be my son
I'm not sure what's up dude hey look how
he stood the car he's following me hey
why you looking at me bro why you
staring
why you staring at me bro you want some
you want some son oh you want some fool
are you gonna look away that's right the
graphics are okay so you have to like
the [ __ ] about this game is this is
how fast you can go all right this is as
fast as you can go what's going on here
then look at this black couple just out
in the streets he got his do-rag or
what's up dude
is he hollering what do you think he's
staying to her right now
she's like well first of all first of
all I don't like how you was talking to
me earlier and he's like look baby look
I'm trying to be a gentleman right now
I'm trying to be a gentleman I look at
the old man I'm talking to him right now
and she's just like flirting like hey so
and then I love you so much like these
games man they going too far with like
they gotta be like they got to go extra
non-white you see what I'm saying
they're like just too many white people
in games so let's black this up look at
this then you go over to this guy like I
don't know like who's this dude I can't
tell what he is either I just I don't
know man I just I don't know you know I
mean I just don't know about this game
like I I can't like decide what they are
but anyways you have to talk to people
you have to pick up stuff like you had
just Alliance status
this guy's like yelling at me and [ __ ]
you go real slow which I don't like whoa
check her out like what is she like
while all the girls got high top fades
man what's that about did she gotta
check out her haircut this [ __ ] is dope
look at this
oh man look at the fade I mean look at
this I mean she got little the baby
hairs right here I don't know what this
chicks about okay so then hey like this
part of the game is infuriating like I
don't care about this so you can skip
past it you just press B but you can't
avoid it like you have to talk to people
and then you have to answer questions
like this part of the game is like I
think this part of the game is just
stupid you know what I mean like I just
don't get this part of the game you know
oh my god oh my god oh my god okay
whatever
bye bye E by E I don't want to talk to
you anymore by E okay so there's that
and then you just had this
like weirdworld let's see what these
people look like oh he's way he's
talking to a chicken a helmet like oh my
god imagine you want a date and like you
get there and she got this on like um
can I see what you look like girl like I
mean the booties not bad you know what I
mean the body's bangin but she got to
cover her she got a butter face she got
a butter face then there's a nut what's
up wit okay I don't know this girl looks
like the one white girl in the bunch
but they all got the same haircut just
see just dude I just don't get it y'all
this guy there [ __ ] he sort of he's
sort of Samoan ish I don't know all
right so you have to walk around and
talk to people and that's how you get
missions you know what I mean you know
you have to get like you get these
missions from the different people you
talk to or they're frightened check them
out wait wait why is that guy talking
like that what the [ __ ] what who's this
guy who's he talking like it doesn't
make any sense
see what this guy sounds like oh let's
check out this guy's glasses and helmet
situation they looking at me like um we
try to have a conversation dude and you
all in it okay but anyway that's dumb
argue so then you go to this thing this
is like a bizarre you can like buy [ __ ]
for your character like but I don't
understand it Oh God why does anybody
have a white voice
it cost to to contract you Oh Michel OTT
it cost me a lot girl okay this is what
this department Auk about look how long
this conversation is you have to have
what this person is so freaking long man
like who wants to talk to somebody this
long oh Jesus okay bye nobody was about
to you bye alright so you come to this
area and this is where you have your
shoot your suit so imma play with this
guy right now so this is like the big
like Colossus sky so you get in I mean
it look the special effects and the
graphics are pretty dope like that looks
great you know what I mean but let me
check the chat now y'all what y'all
talking about in here I don't know I
don't see nothing you guys ain't saying
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
okay so then this is like you pick your
mission now first when I first got this
this was pretty you know it's pretty
confusing Oh
and then here's like you put like
consumables here I'm just trying to
figure out what this is about
oh look at this for slightly oh wow I've
never known what this is y'all for a
single expedition increased marksman's
rifle damage okay I don't know if I have
a marksman's rifle though so that's I
think I do okay then I don't know what I
see I don't get all this [ __ ] but I
guess you craft stuff okay and then you
are I see now and then you put it there
okay there it is
okay there you go they so you can only
have one slot to you rank up right so
that'll they help your gameplay okay
that makes sense
excuse me then you start to expedition
now this is a beautiful looking game I
got to say it really is a beautiful game
but like it's not necessarily fun all
the time but you'll see i'ma play and
you guys will see I don't know where
Steve is I'm not Steve's keeper y'all
it's not my turn to watch him all right
I'm gonna go fullscreen game so you guys
could see how beautiful the game is
you're not I'm an y'all there we go we
don't go fullscreen Griffin
go burn we gotta get that up there it is
come on oh that way good rude I don't
know why that makes me laugh every time
alright so anyways I don't know why this
game is hated I'm looking at the chat
right now I don't know
I think the game's uh it's okay you
never mean make sure my sound is okay in
here you know I don't know why it's a
dude
yeah people hate this game you know a
Mike am like I'm a gaming cam girl as I
was happening oh [ __ ] I say here you go
so now we had this mission so these are
other characters you play with you know
I mean I saw a [ __ ] talks too
much trade up talks too much
wait I got to turn this down sure when
dis Corvis so you can fly which is
pretty dope I mean look at that that
looks beautiful right but then people
die so easy which doesn't make any
freaking sense oh you know what I need
to do is I need to make a party chat
real fast
[Music]
wait wait wait how do you make that [ __ ]
oh no how did you make the chat I don't
know where's the chat controls where you
can make the chat invite only I don't
know how to do it I don't know you leave
the party cuz you're gonna hear people
talking but I'm not talking to them so I
took my mic out so they keys
[ __ ] can't hear me but anyways
this is the game y'all
you fly let me get my fly oh you like
rescue your partners which is like
really annoying especially if you're
playing one of these matches where you
have to get rescue you can't like
respawn and when you can't respawn is so
wack you know I don't like it at all
when you can't respawn you know I mean
oh no but it's like fun like this guy I
mean it looks I don't know why we're in
the dark damn I got some nighttime [ __ ]
so here's some one of the enemies so I
have like a flamethrower so that's
pretty dope look at that fool burning
you and then you can throw like a I have
let go I'm I'm a big flame guy in this
guy this guy's mister flames via but she
had these like kind of missions that you
have to do with other people but then
like look how your health gets low so
when your health gets low you have to
find this light it takes so long for
your health to come back see I just died
freaking annoying and that's what
happens it's so annoying when you die
and then you know now I have to sit
around here wait for one of these [ __ ]
to come pick me up all this guys doing
it alright good job
so that guy's talking like somebody
cares so there's some random white guy
talking in the chat so sorry guys
wait is this do I have a marksman rifle
I don't know if this is a marksman rifle
not supposed to be more damaged okay see
those things like you pick up ammo or
those little red things right there
that's how you get like put your power
back those little red things
so this misses we have to find eight of
these like things that are just like
floating around someplace and I can't oh
my god
and that's it I got I don't even know
how I went down that's why this game is
wack like you don't even see what hits
you and they just you're just down for
the count
sucks
[Music]
yeah this game is a grind
oh look Steve is gonna play games
eventually with us again but I don't
know look I'm here by myself right now
cuz this is Griffin gaming episode 6
anthem edition yeah that would look for
the glowy things so this guy gonna get
me up and like this is what I'm saying
like I have to wait for these guys to
get me up and it's so annoying like look
nobody's even trying to get me up that's
so annoying why is somebody in the chat
talking about their penis like I don't
care so you're getting blocked by nobody
cares about your penis
hello from Australia hello Australia
people are this guy's trying to get me
up finally this guy's good thank you see
he just went down I mean like a such a
stupid spot but then they're not even
gonna be able to get me up because I'm
on this rock like an [ __ ]
look at me so stupid I maybe this guy
will help ok here comes a dude I hear
just here to his here it is finally
they're getting me up oh my god
get me up [ __ ] damn
alright alright swing
okay see it the top to the echoes
delivered we have to find them and
they're so stupid to fine oh he goes one
he goes one he goes one is that one well
I thought that was one right there I
guess it's not I mean the flying and
everything is great I think that the
gameplay is pretty smooth but just I
don't think the game itself is fun you
know I don't know this game is just not
I don't know what is what are the game
rankings like what do you how do you
rank a game do you give it like stars
four stars five stars I don't know but
I'm not really a fan oh [ __ ]
what is that energy levels are dropping
I don't know what the accents are about
man it's like the other game they got
like wait what is going on see I don't
even know what's going on that's another
thing she was like you really know you
really don't know what's going on in the
game oh you can hit people with your
shield that's gotta go [ __ ] Oh
God see that thing up there so I'm about
to die and then they shoot you while
you're flying and you just fly out of
the sky like look how long it takes you
to get your power back so you have like
that red bar as your health and you get
a blue bar for shields so and unless you
get some of those like red things you
have to just stand around for a second
and it's just to me ridiculous I know
yeah like if one teammate goes that look
look how long it's taking my goddddd get
his health back like this is not fun
well use your like ultimate I think you
get your health back right away I will
use my ultimate
oh [ __ ] blasted this [ __ ]
blast off son he can we dickory dock son
oh [ __ ] there's already a guy right here
I mean look how fast you died dude [ __ ]
so annoying and then it's like the whole
game what you do is end up like helping
people
wait I don't hit this dude oh my god I
don't know man I don't know I don't know
if I like this game I think I might play
little apex and I'm down again guys down
again you know I think I'm gonna get out
of this mission you know what I'm gonna
quit the game and go back to it that's
what I'm gonna do okay I'm gonna go back
I'm quitting the game I'm going back to
it cuz I just want to go free play so
you could like to see the world I mean I
think it's pretty amazing looking it's a
beautiful looking game but these
missions like when you have it all hard
it's like so hard to play and then like
if you're not playing with your friends
like people or they don't have any
incentive to come pick you up
I miss pretty wack man I don't know yeah
yeah I agree it's very gloomy I'm back
to the chat now
I know I just gave up on my team like by
team but teammate [ __ ] by team daddy's
gone yeah she just played on normal
you're right I should play on normal but
you know I don't like playing games on
normal I want to play hard
I want to go hard I want to be
challenged son daddy wants to be
challenged you know this channel is
about Gerber Gerber no I do not want to
rejoin that session fall on new items
gave you a nice tradition okay I don't
give a [ __ ] all right and then the
loading in this game is like
ridiculously long like that's not fun
either like it shouldn't take so long to
load a game this is a freaking dope ass
computer why is it taking so long
you know okay then go to the chat what's
up Joe Ram I see you in there Chucky's
give us some feedback what's going on
okay yo dawg okay you being the dirty
dude don't let me blow how many block
you I'm not playin pub G pub G is wack
the game is not fun I don't like to
freaking it's just the rendering I'll
plug G is so stupid but imma go through
all the games I'm gonna play this
actually I'm just gonna go through this
I'm gonna go through this one then we'll
play apex and then I'll like I'm gonna
they just fort and I just had a what do
you call it a update so much I could see
what that's about
Rama go play I'm gonna play free play on
this game right now so you guys can see
like all the flying around and
everything how beautiful it looks
I mean it really is a pretty game look
at the detail on the wall like oh these
two is still fighting check him out is
that all they are you shouldn't sound
like that why are you talking like that
- if I went to the Glendale mall and a
do seller cellphones
oh look at this guy stared right at me
hello hi I talk like this stupid let's
see these guys check this dude out this
dude thinks he's so dope look how he's
standing dudes like yeah what's up you
know I'm just waiting for the honey's
you know to me you know I just got this
new instead of a gold tooth this dude's
like I got my gold masks on you know to
me got my gold masks like how come all
the girls have high-top fades what's up
with this world even the white girls got
high-top fades this dude's mad that just
chick right here isn't saying anything
to him he's like yo [ __ ] you don't see
I got the gold mask on like why are you
trying to act like he's gonna be like
why are you all in my game son and she's
like oh just fool thinks I'm gonna turn
around when he got a gold mask on he out
his mind just okay check this check out
okay pretty face I still understand what
the haircut is about in this whole world
check this dude out he got a dumb ass
hat on do you had a stupid I wish you
could hear me
you could hear a dumb your hat is it's
all warrior people check these two out I
mean I'm not gonna say lesbians I'm not
gonna say it
but we all think in it right we all
looking at these two like they trying to
act like they not gonna be what's up
okay so anyway I was thinking you come
over today and you know we do that that
was some eyes there she should be quiet
okay
what do you think no I can't become I
can't just be coming over you know that
I think you should come over yeah this
is that's what the guys that this guy's
just standing here is she trying to
holler look at her she trying to holler
you like yo I know you got your big I'll
see you take oh that's another thing to
do if you had to pick up [ __ ] around
town for some reason alright I'm going
to show you the world I'm gonna play
other [ __ ] oh this dude went full on
check him out he's trying to get around
me he got a dumb mask on and a dumb hat
what what is that why would you wear
that eye is this the fashion in this
world what is that oh my god this is so
stupid
let me see the little kids what are they
looking at okay mom I'm not gonna mess
with kids y'all that's just I draw the
line here we go
oh you know what I should do let me
change imma change my thing so you can
like yet you go this thing called the
forge so they had this thing called the
forge you could because you could be
like four different characters it's sort
of okay I don't know yeah what was up
with that cheese grater mask it didn't
even make any sense to me
oh [ __ ] look you can like change gear
now let me see what I got here
alright fortify affect reduces incoming
damage for 30% for the Atlanta and the
Allies oh that's the one I wanted yes
that is the one I want it right there
okay sweet
alright that's dope what's the
components y'all - we got some these
things like increased like that one has
all blast damages increased by 15% of
base damage so you have like these
things you can get increase combo damage
let's see I don't ever do combos but
wait designer code is unique you already
have one of these items equipped oh do i
what do I wait let me see increased
lightning increase Reserve oh there it
is right here increased combo damage Oh
check that out oh [ __ ]
there you go there you go and crease
that combo damage I don't even know how
to do a combo that's the stupid part
okay you know what I'm gonna play with
this guy again alright anyways wait
when the stewardess is already got
though oh look at that
wait how come that didn't equip that
doesn't make any sense alright so
anyways oh the combos are key I guess
you played this game a lot I don't know
how to play this game Oh check out this
chick's accent why isn't it would talk
you like they're from a Christmas carol
hello I'm from A Christmas Carol I'm -
look at the titties on this one we got
realistically she don't got a bra so
they pay a little droopy their games are
going to fart like they spent so much
time on these titties waiting for you
why she Irish I don't get it
one guy has a cheesegrater mask on and
this chick's Irish it don't even make
any sense
alright here we go
or I'm just gonna play free play we
gonna do some free play and then I'm
gonna go play I'm gonna play a game of
apex I'm gonna play a game of fortnight
and then I'll play a game of pubsey also
how about that guys all right here you
go free play so you okay so when you do
free play you just pick a place you want
to go you know what I'll make it easy no
I want it to be hard cuz that's how you
get good [ __ ] all right here we go I'm
going there it is
oh so I don't know if I hate anthem I
really don't know I haven't decided if I
just I don't like it or not you know
what I mean I haven't really I don't
have a strong opinion either way I just
don't think it's like I don't think it's
fun enough you know what I'm saying
you like these new overlays y'all you
know I don't even need to have an
awesome times I just had this one on
like yo hey so you can see like the full
beauty of the game of Griffin gaming
good beginning
oh [ __ ] hit the mic sorry
what she's saying in chat y'all
ya know I got to get to level 25 the
problem is I just unlocked another
character but like you have to like I
don't know kind of play from scratch in
terms of like building up guns and
materials cuz that other character is
not very strong yet I don't have a lot
of like all those ordinances and like -
all the little things you have to adjust
on your character it doesn't really have
the stuff yet so I haven't really played
with it I play with this character this
big one and I play with the fast one the
little one that flies around real fast
and like does like a cutting thing
alright so anyway here's the game y'all
look how beautiful that the thing is so
when you fly I mean the flying is pretty
beautiful right you can slow down and
then you can hover like the hovering is
pretty dope but then you then you
overheat and they send you down to the
ground so Billa I mean it's pretty
beautiful I mean it's a pretty beautiful
game you know I mean I'm not gonna lie I
mean look at that I mean that's just
dynamic [ __ ] oh [ __ ] somebody's shooting
at me and when you play free play like
there's like these little public event
missions that you could join with other
people who are playing free play and
that's how you get like materials to
build things and get money and stuff
like that so I mean I mean that part of
this guy actually kind of kind of nice I
mean I just wish to gain was like like
better fighting action like I just want
like a bunch of monsters coming at me
and I want to be able to shoot them all
down not like one monster that's like so
hard to kill sometimes you have to just
make you fun you know that's where I
think oh this that's what I think it's
kind of wack
you know okay so I have this gun so I
got the flamethrower son
look at this look at that view right
there oh yeah that's it right there the
Sun view like this engine is like
spectacular right ah and this is
spectacular
oh [ __ ]
so let's shooting at me what what's
going on okay see sometimes random like
these are the things you don't mess with
you but you can't shoot them if you want
so if you're a dick you shoot them so
I'm a dick
oh and then you have to do this kind of
stuff too so you had this thing right
here so you have to harvest like
whatever and I don't know what the hell
I just got but this is the free place
where you get all your materials to like
build [ __ ] you know all these like
whatever the little currency and other
stuff in the game which to me is like
really weird it's like really weird
currency you know so I don't understand
about how that works but it's still
pretty you know like I say it's a pretty
dynamic game in terms of like the look
and feel but I don't know if I
necessarily I mean will I still want to
play it so then these dogs come you know
I mean I don't know I don't dad should
I've killed the dogs I think you do they
they will attack you if you don't I
don't know if they attack let me see if
they attack I don't they did too also
they're not on the free play you have to
like just this one mission up here you
have to like complete the challenges of
the Legionnaires you have to find these
tombs and I have no [ __ ] idea what
this stuff is man no idea oh it's
crafting materials all right I see I see
what you guys are saying chat you guys
are super helpful right now I really
appreciate it let me move the chat over
so I could see it better all right oh
yeah okay here these guys you get to
kill these guys
yeah sorry I've made myself more mating
that self stronger [ __ ] Oh what
happened what just happen
well this guy's still alive wow that
looked like it hurt man
so I don't know if there's some kind of
like oh wait wait
okay so then so then like this [ __ ] over
here this will be like like a public
event mission that you could play with
other people or maybe this is the maybe
I found one of these places
oh [ __ ] y'all look at this Willie how do
you put that down there you go
oh [ __ ] I found one guardian of the dawn
oh [ __ ] look at that I did I'd actually
did some [ __ ] I completed a mission in
the game completion the [ __ ]
says open you have been judged wait I
don't understand what the [ __ ] going
on do you open this or not
how do you open it hold to open guys I
have no idea what the [ __ ] going on
guardian of the dawn guardian of the
dawn okay well I found one of those
things so there you go complete the
challenges of I don't understand what
the hell this game is about man I don't
know if I'm supposed to go back there
cuz the door didn't open sometimes the
game gets stuck to like it doesn't work
you know so that's pretty wack but
anyway that's anthem that's anthem guys
it's pretty stupid so I'm gonna play
let's go to Apex now I'm gonna play one
game at Apex yeah I don't know about
these apex skills
I'm missing a challenge a challenge
yeah I agree this game was fun for about
two minutes anthem as' and then after
that you're like okay why am I still
playing this cuz you're just not I want
to shoot stuff but you don't want
Rockets flying off my thing and get the
flying and all that [ __ ] is good but
it's just I don't know it just doesn't
it's missing something
yeah I'm gonna play one game of all
these games now guys alright so we're
gonna do a picks legend to see how I do
perks turn this is more like ethnic
legends that's what they should call
this game ethnic legends ethnic nerds
you know I'm gonna play with this person
I don't know who you are they just said
to play but I'm gonna play with you I
don't know if you're in the game not but
we're not gonna talk so sorry guy I'll
play with you but I'm not gonna talk
with you I like division - I like
division division is a great game but
that game is like so time-consuming like
with division you spend like 40 minutes
like adjusting your guns that's what was
happening with me on on division you
know so so guys I'm about to go in and
play these games I'm gonna play apex
right now so if somebody sends me an
invite I'm gonna accept it right now and
boom well I'll play with you but it's
too late cuz I'm already in the game I'm
already playing
yeah I'm looking at the chat right now
and I agree I think that anthem is
actually missing something like it looks
beautiful it's a beautiful game but it
is totally missing something right now
and I don't I don't know what that is
but you know it's just it doesn't have
that that umph you know Dan this dude
that's 42 kills I have 13 kills the
student invited me only has 14 kills so
maybe I could do it yeah I have Grand
Theft Auto two guys but I'm not playing
that today all right let's see where we
gonna go
what should we go y'all okay go over
there okay here we go jump my star I'll
be going over here oh my god where are
we going
okay now this is a beautiful game - I
love this game I can't believe that this
game is free you know what I mean I just
I can't believe this game is free just
how beautiful it is and it's a smooth
game I love how it plays but I don't
know man it's like I say it's missing
something
why is he going in this tree okay we are
going far Dan we going far I'm going
over here [ __ ] that let's go let's go
please have a gun in here see I I can't
stand when there's no gun okay here we
go
a wingman wingman's pretty good how's
this [ __ ] already taking fire
okay we're gonna get this and this
these [ __ ] are already taking
fire too like I'm only oh there's a guy
right there you see that guy let me see
if I can get him what oh all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] did a
disappearing move on me that's my move
that was dope just nothing in here man
okay here we go I got me a helmet I got
me a helmet
oh is this a gun no grappling what
character does that grappling that's
pretty dope I mean did you see me I was
shooting that guy like full-on shooting
and I didn't even make a dent someone
know I hate this game sometimes man
alright here we go here we go this is a
gun I like I could shoot this gun Oh
should I hear someone why is it all
helmets in this [ __ ] oh my god oh my
should I go help this guy oh my god dude
this is so frustrating okay dude
this [ __ ] is way over in another
area dude oh my god I don't even know
what to do right now alright let me just
see if I can say oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh man
[Music]
okay well that's it guy hey all right I
need one more of this I need one more
one more one more one more okay I'm
gonna do one more
apex legend alright
wait let me leave this dudes thing it's
already played with you bro and I don't
like you that was pretty bad no that was
pretty bad oh my god
all right I don't know who this is okay
alright alright dude I'm gonna play with
you zoom motto whatever the [ __ ] your
name is
let's go then I'm gonna play with this
dude because you sent me very persistent
sent five freakin messages so I'm not no
you're not you're not
I'm not joining your party okay we're
not gonna talk but I will play with you
what do you mean this sensitivity
somebody said I need to turn the
sensitivity up what do you mean
so that one of my settings what should I
do here controller Oh two terms how
cookie your your view wrote oh okay
alright sensitivity the terms likely you
view rotates when Amy uh-oh low weight
so I turn it up high I've never seen
this stuff before this is okay I don't
know let's see what happens all right
we're matchmaking Griffin is cell
elitist shut your [ __ ] mouth piece of
[ __ ] how dare you yeah I mean how dare
you that's why I think of you
somebody said turn that mug up Toby
fooled you made the right choice this
time here we go guys
piece of [ __ ] I didn't know Brody really
well I knew him well enough you know I
mean I've known him over the years you
know it's like working with somebody for
a long time you don't necessarily know
their personal life but you see them all
the time do shows you have you know
sometimes you go out to eat special
moments like that you know I wish more
people would have like all the love that
he's getting now I wish he would have
gotten it in life so I am recommending
to people you know mental illness is a
thing so like if you know anybody that
is feeling down or there's someone
that's taking medication and they're a
good friend of yours you got to stay on
top of them because you know that
medications thing is like it really can
be a killer you know and like they can
make a snap decision the thing that they
can't come back from when you're in the
middle of medicating or like you got
take yourself off medication and get on
new medication there's a real like
period right there in between that it's
best not to be alone but anyway that's
all I'm gonna say on that all right here
we go
just the last game oh here we go
ethnic legends all right oh [ __ ] guys
stop
I hate when there's no gun I hate it why
here's a gun oh man this [ __ ] house
shotgun pistol is so stupid but I have
to take it just cuz I need a gun right
now the shotgun pistol is like the
stupidest gun in the game who are you Oh
back back back oh [ __ ] way I want that
oh man
okay I gotta get this give me a helmet
all right give me this backpack nice I'm
gonna stay with this guy cuz this is the
guy that I don't I don't know him but
you know I mean oh please it could be a
good gun in here y'all I love a pea 2020
all right what is this [ __ ] oh here we
go oh I love a pea 2020 actually P 20 20
my favorite like easiest gun to shoot
you know I mean open this [ __ ] up son oh
[ __ ] alright I'll take that
[Music]
okay alright
what is all this [ __ ] I'm gonna take
that what is this gun semi-auto light
sniper rifle no listen that's why all
right here we go y'all here we go oh oh
I take this gun oh [ __ ] instead of the
shotgun yeah I'm taking this okay wait I
gotta drop this [ __ ] I don't want that
okay there we go
don't need that [ __ ] oh there's [ __ ]
shooting man where wait let me check
this [ __ ] first bro um oh [ __ ] there's
an energy mo I don't need none of this
okay let's go well you want to go I'm
following you bro oh [ __ ] wait nope I
don't need that Duke you loser appointed
let's go if you ask me Oh baby hey this
game I mean look how beautiful this game
is man look at that the Sun [ __ ] and um
I mean look at it and this game is free
they were smart you know I don't know
how they're making money but there I
think they just probably took the engine
from a game they already had and they
were like well let's just give this away
cuz they're losing that to fortnight in
all these other games
I mean it makes sense you know just give
us free [ __ ] you know I mean I'll give
me that give me that give me that give
me that give me that good job son
yeah don't wave at him any wave at him
I can't even wave at [ __ ] here
we go y'all here we go yo oh yes yes
okay I suspect you will find something
here should I grab this or should I keep
this - - oh let me get this ninja star
the ninja stars kind of dope y'all use
the ninja star but it's just hard to
like get a kick ball [ __ ] oh [ __ ] wait
let's still just to saying um okay I
don't need none of this
what is this a wing man I already have a
wing man is this a wing man I have yeah
I have a wing man wait no I don't have a
wingman check it this wing man let me
get this wing man and this okay there we
go
wait what is he saying okay all right
dude these dudes are already taking off
like I just play I know it's the same
company that makes anthem so I think
it's kind of dope that they made this I
almost wished they'd make anthem be like
this kind of game imagine anthem like
you could fly I mean I just don't
understand the choices I was if flying
let me get to zip line you know I mean
like it would be dope if like they had a
battle royale and anthem wait how come I
can't dude I can never do this [ __ ] dude
how do you jump up there you go
yes yeah oh okay okay okay what is this
gun all right I need that thank you
all right okay good we're inside all
right we got it we got it son
oh wait who's that out there oh oh [ __ ]
we gasps trapped in [ __ ] - trap -
trap oh we do we in a circle I'll we're
knee-deep in the circle right now this
is good delivering care package Oh what
is this
I can't use that whoo I can use that
though thank you thank you how do you
get outside where I think we're gonna
stay inside here man I'm with this guy
though I think we should go all right
here we go
yeah yeah I need another game I mean I
spent money on anthem and I'm a little
bit like I wish I didn't I wish I didn't
buy anthem I'm actually I'm actually
gonna say that out loud I wish I didn't
buy anthem so now it's like you buy it
and you feel like you're freakin forced
to you know you know I mean we say our
301 here what kind of gun is that oh
this guy took it Oh nobody's over here
this is actually a good area oh [ __ ]
y'all we might do it ya son sniper stock
here level 3 I have nothing on this gun
I have everything on this gun oh good
call these guys are good this guy like
you put up that thing up behind us
that's pretty dope let me get the
syringe crack behind us oh [ __ ] okay all
right give me that mid range optics son
oh yeah yeah yeah wait is the close
range better than I think the close
range is better right oh [ __ ] look at
that party in the ring - damn alright
this might be a good one guys
you might see some some oh look I need
this wing man okay what is this no don't
need that wait what is this [ __ ] over
here no I don't need a peacekeeper oh
[ __ ] a gold knock down shield wait how
come I can't pick that up oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right here we go
here we go yo here we go go so what's
the what's the Sun every yo
wait how is he saying all that stuff
okay here we go guys the champion has
been eliminated i straight-up like these
guys the one over here oh man I wish I
can make my guy say that stuff play
close attention to that area I love all
that stuff let's see let's see if I
could see people coming
oh [ __ ] check out 100 oh my god I just
scared myself oh my god all right oh oh
so if you hold I know you can ping
things but how do you make it say like
you know defend this area and all that
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] somebody coming in right
let's go come on I guess we're just
gonna stay in this area
I like this gas trap this actually we
got a little fortification going on
right here son you don't want to see us
with 9 squads left you don't want to see
us I just I just want to get a kill guys
can I get a kill
so you can tag this gas trap all here's
how you do it okay you hold it down oh
well there's a hostel okay
oh [ __ ]
we don't want this guy throwing a
grenade in right [ __ ] what is
happening oh my god dude oh [ __ ] oh that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] affects me oh I got to
get out of here use a syringe oh [ __ ] I
gotta get out oh my god I couldn't get
out of there guys that was terrible
okay that's enough apex alright let's
play are we played apex
now we're gonna play call to turn on
burger okay I need to like wait let me
go - oh man I don't know why did that
that was like so stupid that was like
the dumbest that was the dumbest
gameplay you know what I mean
I should have left that room but I
thought the guy was trapped you know
what I mean like oh man that's stupid no
no that was just really stupid well I
did what I can to I try my best but I
guess my best wasn't good enough y'all
still in here oh no I got game a DD
right now I'm just trying to like play
all the games right now for y'all so
I'll play apex I played Anthem apex I'm
gonna play a couple games I call the
duty and then oh but i'ma play solo
blackout that's how I'm gonna do it
y'all what is this league play I haven't
played this in a while what's all this
[ __ ] Oh solo there you go deploy all
right guys here we go i I just don't get
with with this game I don't get what is
all that [ __ ] mean like I get character
it I just don't get how the money works
and call of duty I don't get how to fix
[ __ ] how to make my character look
different I don't understand it at all
when I got to update you got like a
thousand coins to do some [ __ ] but I
don't know what it does I don't get it
I know I can't just have Bobby and Steve
on all my podcast y'all just you know I
mean you know gonna edit video
I gotta edit this video
[Music]
all right we write this in here
oh here we go
yeah now see as I see the difference
between this game and apex I guess they
look about the same I mean wouldn't you
say I mean I think that they have the
same kind of like beauty you know if
that if that makes sense at all
[Music]
okay it makes you smash that subscribe
button right there
alright what are they gonna start this
game like a you can just go punch me
look at this dude how do you get your
character to look like that
this guy's got a freaking kilt on punch
him in his face for having that kilt on
how dare you look at this guy this guy's
all fancy I don't know I don't get this
game at all man I do not get this game
this guy's just shootin people all got a
guy just cursed kindly [ __ ] off
everybody's got an accent today in this
game oh here we go y'all where should I
go dude I do not know how to jump in
this game y'all
oh man where should I go I don't know
where to go cuz you by yourself in this
[ __ ] alright here we go
I think I know how to do the jump now
okay there we go look at me look at me I
believe I can fly we can't sing our
Kelly songs anymore my bet I believe I
can glide oh that's a guy right there oh
no getting this building close that
[ __ ] door oh I got a gun okay there
we go
Oh Oh son Oh son okay then you go
upstairs real quick get that vest
there's somebody in here oh [ __ ] dude I
don't know what to [ __ ] do with this
game man oh there's [ __ ] in
this place I can hear him oh my god dude
let me use my awareness
anything in here nothing I need to get a
better gun this is not gonna do the
trick
yes the closest I gotta get another gun
quick so I pick up this gun yeah why
should I pick up this gun I don't want a
shotgun
I want that oh that's dope wait close
this [ __ ] door man how do you close
the door okay oh my god I'm sweating
already let's just see what this dude
has okay all right oh [ __ ] what does he
have okay give me I need that what am i
doing why am i jumping oh my god how do
you grab [ __ ] why is it jump
okay I see nevermind
okay what is this why my spray-painting
[ __ ] right now
this game is infuriating okay all right
where am I in the circle I'm close I
can't believe I killed that dude right
there man oh my god this is I'm sweating
right now I know this is okay Shh
everybody be quiet why am i telling
everybody be quiet I'm the only
[ __ ] talking all right here we
go oh look at this a little Jeep should
I get the Jeep I'm gonna get the Jeep oh
my god you run so slow in this game oh
here we go here we go y'all here we go
yo here we go yo so what's the scenario
oh why is somebody shooting at me
hey where should I go oh my god is when
I get in a circle oh my god
[ __ ] are already over there oh
this is okay I need some better [ __ ] Oh
dis guns better right I don't even know
I don't even [ __ ] know what is that
right there
seven six I need some 76 yes oh I have
shootin oh I'm just going I need to just
go into rooms blastin for Cal no five
cap okay now I start to understand to
get what you need okay any five six
leave that wait I need seven
yes okay here we go huh close that you
see what's going on outside I'm in the
circle oh I see oh you see that
somebody's in that room over there
why did I do that
why did I [ __ ] do that guys oh my god
oh my god okay yeah I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm doing oh [ __ ] Oh how'd they
kill me dis muhfucka had a [ __ ]
sniper 54th place okay well that was
annoying guys you know camp mode engaged
let's look at the kill cam I need to see
I doesn't Duke oh this [ __ ] had
a sniper rifle goddamn dude how long was
he following me oh this is this is
infuriating look at this look at this oh
my god I got wow wow that was pretty
shitty right there okay
all right okay I think I should do one
more this oh you think I suck okay thank
you thank thank you for that you guys
are the worst I mean obviously I'm
scared you know what I mean like
obviously this is a situation
okay I got a little tie teared up son
I teared up with that I did kill
somebody though how about that though I
did get a kill and that was a that was a
good one
alright I'm gonna play call of duty but
whoever this is sending me a thing I'm
gonna play with you right now all right
so let's go I don't know what's
happening okay I got I think it froze
this game freezes all the time y'all
wait what is domination I don't want to
play domination what the [ __ ] are you
talking about it
he's the party leader why are we doing
domination I want to play black ops okay
see now I got a leave cuz he didn't do
what I wanted to do alright let's go
another blackout Oh
herbs is on there we go I'll play with
this guy this guy no wait I got to put
my
alright guys I got to put my there we go
yeah there it is there it is son
there it is dere did wait let me see if
he invited me to a party yeah let's see
nope I'm not gonna join your party son
all right
there we go there we go there we go wait
wait why am i hearing myself I don't
like that turn it down herbs are you in
the party I don't know what's going on
guys
there we go yo hello where's it yet
yo man let's do this duo's I could just
win I'm streaming right now can you hear
me I'll tell you you hear me way old up
all right hold on [ __ ]
powering on i think i'll spirally on
hello can you hear me hello all right I
had to turn my headset off and on all
right come on we get this victory we're
gonna I'm after this one I'm gonna play
fortnight and then I want to play one
game up up G I'm playing all of them
right now I'm playing them all tonight
I've already done Apex I lost I didn't
get a kill I play one game with this I
got a kill but then I [ __ ] die it was
terrible I know you know what actually
when you play apex you I think it makes
you better I call a duty in terms of
like the firing you know
I think you have liked a little better
yes giving you like a lack of it and
yeah it gives you like a little
advantage so I cuz I don't I never shoot
well I know I'm gonna play too Kay
another time guys I'm gonna do all my
favorite sports games the next time but
right now I'm trying to get this battle
royale victory in one of these games I
didn't happen in Apex
here's Call of Duty playing with my boy
so we'll see what happens look ups of
this game though I don't even do you
think I know that kind of [ __ ]
why would I even know I mean look I want
to know how to get my character to look
dope like that alright well wherever you
want to go aren't you
do we drop yet oh my god
see I'm so used to apex I'm thinking
that I forgot that I had to do this
myself where do we drop in yet yeah look
on the compass and you can kind of see
where I marked all right I see
oh I see I see you I don't know I don't
know if I will make it over there to you
though or does a guy to our left there's
two guys to our left go down in those
houses right there where you're at those
houses right there oh there's a guy in
front of you okay I'm gonna go down to
the gas station doesn't seem to me
anybody coming here come down to the gas
station oh [ __ ]
come on come on come on oh yes Gunn yes
oh okay I got a bunch of [ __ ] already
you guys go son give me that give me
this 12-gauge no I don't need that I
better close this door oh I just saw
this [ __ ] right how can I cut and pick
it up pick it up is that you
OSU [ __ ] you scared me yeah can we go in
this other building did you go in this
other building already and his bathrooms
oh you did you did alright let's go
across the street Dan yeah I've got to
say let's go across the street cuz I
have a gun so are we gonna hit just the
liquor stop I'm gonna hit the roof I'm
gonna hit the roof
cuz there's always [ __ ] on the roof
five six yeah there's like all right
there's a okay I got some armor yes
were there people there's a people in
this other building next to us we're
gonna slide this building right next to
us
Oh what okay there's a gun in here
there's like a Oh censored art here's a
backpack I got the sensor DARPA there's
nothing else in here I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go up top
okay so seven sitting on these 76 oh
[ __ ] I don't need an extra gun there's
another disarmer up here can you ping
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] you can't ping [ __ ] I did I
did a ping move where we going what is
that oh [ __ ] I get this I'm gonna get
I'm gonna grab this [ __ ] rocket
launcher let's go out the back door oh
we were already over there right yeah we
were okay so should we start heading out
the min we should go around wait let me
see oh we're so far away dude we're so
far away maybe we should go through this
tunnel maybe we should go this tunnel to
the left and just go up and around wait
am i following you
i dude you tell me you're leaving okay
cuz yeah yeah over there oh it doesn't
go anywhere okay oh man
you were so far away oh my god wait can
you how do you put down your gun in this
game to run faster oh my god this is
weird playing this as opposed to apex I
have not gotten a win in this game yet
the only only I've only won twice in
Apex and I haven't won in fortnight and
I haven't won in pub G just FYI people
yeah but it didn't go well yeah it's
just I don't even know if I'm gonna play
that yeah it's just I just hate how slow
it is Pub he's just like are you doing
this we're running around
oh you press why no I thought you hold
white now why didn't work guys
oh [ __ ] this thing is coming in it's
right behind me I can't I can't run any
faster than this oh my god oh my god I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna get ya that's
like I feel like I'm going so slow oh
it's on me it's about to pass me where
where where we got to get in this
vehicle we don't got time for this
wait for me okay go
okay
alright here we go oh [ __ ] Oh
oh [ __ ] I was firing on that fool that
was a drive drive by there was a double
drive-by yeah they were in the vehicle
fired at us from the right where where
where I came to see oh wait oh man
oh I should have used my you know what
I'm gonna use my rocket launcher why
didn't I use the rocket launcher oh I'm
not even in it I'm not even in the thing
anymore oh [ __ ] I I'm sorry I forgot you
kick I forgot that you kids we gotta go
okay we're in a circle oh [ __ ] does it
get - oh my god
2:04 she's right there oh [ __ ]
he's right he's coming after me oh I'm
down oh I forgot you oh man let me
spectate well guys that's uh I totally
did something stupid as [ __ ] right there
guys hey don't you know if you wanna if
you wanna
hit the super chat I'm not gonna be mad
at you guys is this one of these ones
where I can't you can't get me up no huh
Oh are we oh we're done we're both done
oh oh oh let's get out of here then I
thought I was watching you how do you
get out of this [ __ ]
I think you'll be we could play it one
more of these since we're playing
together let's play one more of these
how do I can't get out oh there it is
they're just it's different now actually
you go quit game I am left
[Music]
yeah I'm on this basic [ __ ] character
I forgot that like friendly fire is on
in this game that's the only that's a
big difference and then like in this
game if you fall from a long distance
you get hurt too right okay so squat no
wait no done okay so wait okay you go to
character right I can't select any
characters they're all those characters
are locked
oh wait oh no no not a multiplayer
you're right you're right here we go
okay I didn't even know that that's a
thing you go to okay when you go to
character and then oh wow this whole
time I've had this game and I didn't
know this is how you do [ __ ] look at
that alright this is good I'm ready to
go yeah I started streaming 84 why does
have a long stream y'all doing that long
stream that long stream yeah I'm gonna
do fortnight next after this one what
time is it oh [ __ ] I got to go to a show
I even have a show tonight guys you make
sure yes 9 23 I was showed 11 perfect
yeah I'm in LA yeah
okay here we go let's try to get just
victory try to get this victory yeah I'm
going to Vancouver for anybody's in
Vancouver I know someone in Vancouver I
will be in Vancouver on next weekend
Vancouver Canada
next weekend are you up in Canada right
Oh chick Kakkar
I like Chicago some of my favorite
places are in Vancouver where you better
come to the show I'll be at the Yuk
Yuk's in Vancouver next weekend
I would say let's check out the new
place well you need to tell me like
where it went to jump dude you can't
just like you know probably still we're
still in right yeah
all right just a little cluster oh I see
what you're going yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
look at me learning how there's a zombie
thing over there though right isn't that
a zombie thing that light oh wait is
that me oh I thought that was somebody
but it was actually I don't think
anybody's here
understand there's like a little Jeep
right here - oh [ __ ] look at this 50 Cal
there's 50 Cal in here but there's no
guns do this I hate that man here's a
backpack nice they tried to ping a
shotgun yeah yeah oh [ __ ] I hear a lot
of shooting oh yes okay what is this
name five five armor plate uh-huh
give me that five five oh we could this
is this is a gold mine of an area I like
jumping through windows that's my
favorite [ __ ] okay yeah all right what
you got
[Music]
oh yes okay I I'm ready to guns ready to
go I got a backpack okay okay
okay wait I just see someone no I think
we the only ones over here are we in the
circle also you said oh we're in a
circle - yes yes only to paint can yeah
but who wants to do that in the middle
of in the middle yeah I mean in the
middle of the game I'm yeah paint and
[ __ ] in the middle of the game all right
I got enough amo all right all right how
do you get out of this how do you how do
I get on oh wait wait I'm not on yet
okay there you go go
I think I think we could have rated all
those buildings we're not gonna be just
in a circle oh yeah how do you get off
again oh oh [ __ ] why are they going so
fast oh [ __ ] this is a serious situation
racing I don't want that bull [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I hear another one oh [ __ ] don't
walk in front of my shooting I almost
shot you got a nice oh yeah okay
I don't have I need some warmer or
something yeah there is
oh [ __ ] here's a gold gun right here a
gold SWAT I'm taking this [ __ ] yeah but
this is my rampart right here I left I
think I had a bunch of stuff on it I
don't know what it's over there fast
okay give me that okay like it oh don't
think I want to extend it over fast
right yeah I want more ammo only certain
guns take extend my god you have a
backpack I got that back oh wait
9 millimeter all I need oh man I have
two guns that need 9 millimeter that's
the only thing
woo swordfish oh I hear something what
was that oh it was over here where wait
I don't see right here oh okay where did
you put that rampart you said there's a
fine okay
acid bomb Oh medic it seven six nine
I'll need any seven six how do you drop
[ __ ]
it was my inventory
oh here we go here we go now I'm a
cattle need just 40 cal so how do you
drop [ __ ] I don't know how to drop oh
here we go
I hear this don't need this five six I
don't need this I'll need two fifty Cal
get out from behind oh [ __ ]
from where well let's just get this is
right here I'm going into some house
over here you know I mean oh [ __ ]
there's like a armored perfect somebody
was already here so late where oh I see
them I'm staying in the house yeah where
are you oh we could get you know what we
could slide down the hill while they're
fighting no no I'm saying you go down to
here I'm just saying we can look down
here yeah
let's go through this you want to just
hit this there's online oh [ __ ] what was
that
I think somebody's shooting at me hunt
in there oh my god
let's just go they follow me let's get
out of there so you can get into the
circle because there cuz they're coming
they're gonna be coming this way we can
ambush him like we can ambush him right
here by this rocks there they're gonna
pass us you know what I mean I don't
know what am i what am I talking about
oh sweet Oh super chat got a dollar
[Laughter]
alright let me see what is that is that
fit tell us ammo I need it oh no no
9-millimeter here on my Hyrum oh [ __ ]
look you ready
Oh shadows beautiful sure didn't did
they turn around
yeah oh they're coming in there I've got
200 rounds right there oh sweet
well my ammo is full perfect all right I
don't need that I don't need none of
this [ __ ] oh my god you get a grapple
gun or not no wait don't I don't even
know wait underbarrel no what do you see
where would that even be no I don't oh I
see what you're saying oh that's how you
do that well that's pretty amazing
you learn something new every day what
we're in the circle here someone lost
just me wait hey which gun should I use
this one's better further collapse exact
alright here we go y'all here we go here
we go
oh that scared the [ __ ] out of me my
sensors are blown I'm all sweaty
my hands are all sweaty and [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you would think well here's the thing
right there I could see the blue like if
we go out oh no no we're about to be
where we're actually not in the circle
right now oh my god that buildings has
to be full of people 19 seconds yeah
this has already been all man inside the
building is in the circle oh look at
this man people have already been in
here careful we're still not in the
circle let's go across to that tube
across you know what I mean trying to
see if I see anybody up oh my god yeah
but you're not in the circle - now we're
in the circle was it while somebody went
out the door over here man they
definitely went to the other circle
I'd give me that what is that no I don't
want that [ __ ] it is okay
know what I got a recon car well we
should be careful they're probably
coming in this building too you know
what I mean like just kind of watch my
body just stay in this room watch my
body I'm gonna use this recon car and
okay all right all right
close that door now okay okay the the
circles collapsed oh my god you know if
you hear anything all right the circle
just collapsed and I don't see anybody
in I don't see anybody in the room yeah
yeah yeah no no we're out of the circle
right now though let me open this door
like this room in this other room we're
in the circle we're in the next circle
in this other room sort of so we can
just we could just jump out this window
when it's time you know what I mean wait
oh [ __ ] did I just see someone I see
someone across up across up top like
eight you see him moving yeah
oh my god I'm getting so nervous left to
your left to your left there's another
guy oh my god that was that was great
shoot him
sorry okay oh there's a grappling hook
take the the the okay four times scope
always got level two armor trophy system
whatever the [ __ ] that is
oh wait level two armor when you put a
trophy system down it blows up all right
we're still in the circle let's go this
room this room right here I think so
wait can you watch me wait obviously
where is that where is that [ __ ] at oh
okay I do have ok repair armor oh oh I
don't need to repair my okay boom all
right done
I don't even know what that was need one
more yeah I do
I got it okay oh here's the thing is
we're in it we're in it well let's see
if somebody comes to our left you know
what I mean because they're coming where
how do you use a grapple though okay so
you go up okay quick quick okay got it
okay okay and you're gonna use but what
should go where okay
and have to shoot the corner ha ha lay
down lay down
really I'll shoot you right this is
beautiful Oh
oh man we had it we shoulda stayed up on
the roof
oh man okay well that was that guys all
right okay oh wait
fifth place though not bad not bad okay
now I'm gonna go to fortnight that's not
gonna last long for me all right man
thanks for playing
you too that was herbs she's a pretty
cool dude all right guys we're going to
fortnight for nerd
which I do not know how to play so it's
gonna be a very short game okay we're in
fortnight let me edit my video to let
people know that I'm PI and far now
yeah playing for now I know that
settings
I'm not gonna join your party baby I'm
not gonna join your party baby bear
oh here we go
for tonight is loading loading foot
night oh wait let me edit the video all
right so we've played Apex Call of Duty
I don't think I'm gonna get to the pub
gee guys I'm taking that out of the
description I'm not gonna get to the pub
G but I am gonna get to Fort I'm gonna
do a couple games a fortnight and we'll
see what happens I am pretty disgusting
at fortnight I don't know how to build I
don't know how to do anything so bear
with me you know
okay I know I'm gonna have a I'm gonna
make some music y'all daddy gonna make
some music
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys here we go for tonight okay
how do I do this uh wait Battle Royale
uh select game mode create creative I
don't know what the [ __ ] that means how
do you just can I just start the game I
don't I don't know how to do this [ __ ]
to play fort night battle okay you know
what I'm gonna play with this guy but I
don't know how to oh there you go I
haven't played this game is so long I
don't know what the hell I'm doing but
this is fortnight on burning
[Music]
what is happening right now look uh what
was that
okay collect all in clothes I don't know
what is happening right now can I just
play God no dude I have no idea I don't
want to purchase [ __ ] dude
oh [ __ ] girl oh oh that was dope
oh [ __ ] oh boom boom boom pop boom pop
boom okay how do you get out of this
guys I don't know how to start the
freaking game oh here's the lobby ready
oh here we go me and two fish two fish
one cup that's funny
two fish one cut is a funny name
I was that what all that stuff is I have
no idea what all this stuff is but
whatever we doing it y'all we doing it
wait am I here let me check the sound of
the stream real fast
you know I don't know if the sound is
synced up it might not be synced up
hello oh [ __ ] what is that oh my god
what are we playing yet no oh this is
just a oh god I'm like I was like oh
here we go already there is a lag on my
sound wait I'm trying to I don't know
how to fix that goddamn it y'all that's
so annoying lag where it where it where
I don't see it
oh I see it I see it I see it we jump in
oh I see what you're saying
yeah I'm gonna have to fix my stream lag
but I can't figure it out sorry guys
we're working this all out oh right
Oh to get to that no I think we're good
yeah I think it's pretty good
uh-uh I forgot we'll decide to ask you
this game actually looks a little better
again than it did from before oh I
forgot you can like okay I don't know
what I write oh here we go here we go
how do you switch okay there we go
switch to my gun
oh [ __ ] I found something oh yeah got a
gun with a silencer on it okay what is
this ammo I don't know what this is
small shield why do you drink that
already but how do you drink [ __ ] right
away
what do you press Oh got it got it got
it got it got it got it got it
okay I see it now okay okay oh [ __ ] okay
I'm gonna get this candy
okay okay okay Lily wait I see something
over here if I don't know what it is
rifts oh you can do that thing again
okay I got it okay got a damage trap you
can't jump over [ __ ] oh I just seem so
slow wait I don't know where I'm going
oh here we go okay all right here we go
here we go here we go wait okay here we
go
okay I'm going but we can't get in this
why can't I just get in this car
alright shhh okay wait but what is this
why did I just do I just ping something
oh my god this is so much slower than
the other games it's like a frustrating
yeah this is for tonight y'all for 9:00
everybody likes to talk about fortnight
can you shoot each other no huh mm so
they all have something special all
somebody did this or did you just build
this but how do you build [ __ ]
then what being the trigger
right well how do I get how do I get out
of this build here we go normally my god
it took forever Jesus
oh [ __ ] alright I'll take that
wait how do you drop [ __ ] when I'm over
it okay what like I want to Oh got it
okay I want to drop this one oh man yes
another thing you're just not used to
god dammit you think you go like I shot
the last guy was playing with I shot him
that plane call it they call the duty
cuz I didn't know Oh God see fortnight
is just the worst just gave us so like
it's just so boring you just running
around doing nothing you know what I
mean
okay oh yeah you can't you can't ping
you can ping [ __ ] you can ping stuff in
this game we what's that over there here
is small okay I'll take that that's not
me
did you shoot him
I can't oh my god I don't know how to
get out of it here wait I'm coming all
my gut oh my god
I'm like trapped in this you know what I
got to go to my [ __ ] axe
I don't know how to get out of here well
here we go here some stairs oh my god
I'm not a horrible teammate where are
you where are you where is this guy is
he still here oh this I got this
silencer
oh wait wait there's a great gun over
here when I picked this up Oh compact
your shotgun what is happening okay
why gotta be debate he's not in here
oh [ __ ] oh man we're [ __ ] around oh I
can't oh my god oh my god we're so far
away
we I think I have what is this oh I'm
dead I was terrible fortnight is
terrible terrible yeah I died hello
hello I don't know what happened
hello patchnotes
lobby well I think my fortnight you know
what guys I think that's it for me yeah
I think my game crashed my xbox just
froze so that's that's pretty annoying
but anyway that was I'll reconnect your
controller is what it is oh well there
we go I don't know what's going on but
anyways yeah that was that man you know
we played a little games pin little
games do a little days night so anyways
guys this is Griffin gaming I think that
sound is a little off so I got to work
on that figure out how to [ __ ] to make
that not do that but I thank everybody
for watching live this was a long stream
good for gaming episode 6